Um so today we start a three-part series
on the French Revolution which I believe
to be the most significant event in
human history. Okay. So let me very
quickly explain its significance. So um
as I keep on mentioning in this class,
it is the rel religious worldview that
underpins society and civilization. It
is what allows society to function. And
um to oversimplify, there have been four
major religious worldviews in human
history. Okay, so let's go over them
briefly. The first is what we call the
animistic and this is basically during
the ice age when we were hunter
gatherers and we were just roaming the
earth. Okay. Right. And there are three
major key words that underly this
worldview. Uh
balance,
harmony, and
oneness. We do not believe that we were
different from the plants, the animals
uh that lived on this planet. We were
one with them. We were interconnected
with them. We didn't fear death because
life and death were part of the same
continuous cycle. Okay. So this is the
idea of the animistic
um worldview. From then we moved on to
the
polytheistic polytheistic many
gods and the three main ideas that
underpin the polytheistic worldview are
action,
ritual and fate.
No one, not even the gods, can escape
their
fate. Our fate has been
pre-ordained. What courage is is the
willingness to
embrace with with honor and with dignity
your fate. So think of Hector as he is
about to battle Achilles. He knows he is
going to get killed and he's afraid. He
shakes, but he still confronts his fate
and he dies. And that's what's expected
of you in the Viking world, in the Greek
world, in the Roman world. To face your
death with honor and dignity, to live
your life with courage, action, but in a
ritualized manner. Okay? In a way that
the community expects of you and to
embrace your faith no matter what it is.
Okay? That's is a polytheistic
worldview. Then this uh leads us to the
monotheistic
worldview. The monotheistic. Okay. So
the monotheistic are the Jews, the
Christians and the Muslims. The three
major ideas that underpin the
monotheistic worldview
are
faith,
orthodoxy, and
truth. There is an eternal truth called
God. We must have faith in him. And
faith and truth are expressed through
orthodoxy. There is a set of beliefs
that you cannot question that you must
believe and you must uh live your life
according to this orthodoxy. Okay. So
these are these are three major ideas
underlying monotheistic.
Now we move to the modern period. Okay.
Another word that we can use for modern
is uh dism.
Okay, dism you may not have heard of
this but the idea of dism is that there
is a god. God created the
universe but then he left us. He doesn't
care about what happens anymore because
the world he created was perfect. And it
is up to us to
understand the perfect laws of the
universe and then perfect our lives
according to these laws. Okay. So let's
say you have thism. This is important
because dism is the founding religion of
both the American as well as the French
revolutions. All right. And there are
three major beliefs that underpin dism.
The first is
reason. Okay. So rather than faith, we
have to use our reason because that's
the gift that God gave us before he
left. We are able to using logic, using
intuition, using skepticism to
understand how the world works. Okay?
Reason. All right? But reason by itself
is not enough. You have to engage in
debate in order to fully use our reason.
You may not able to reason out for
yourself the truth, but when but in a
debate, you're able to hear out the
truth. Okay? And if we do this, if we
continue to exercise our reason, if we
continue to engage in debate, what is
often called um the marketplace of
ideas, this will lead to the idea of
progress.
Okay. So what's happened is that the
modern period is responding to the
Christian period
um by replacing faith with reason
orthodoxy with debate and truth with
progress. Okay. And these three ideas
reason, debate and progress are the
foundations of the period we live in
today called the modern period. It is it
is about these three ideas are the
foundations of our school
system for our universities for our for
scientific um institutions. Okay, does
that make sense? All right. Now, having
gone through these four different
periods, I want to do some analysis.
Okay. The first analysis is to explain
to you how these changes manifest
manifested themselves. So the animistic
period is the most natural. It's what
the mo it's what makes the most sense.
Quite honestly, if animals had a
religion, it would probably be an
animistic religion. Okay. So how do we
transition from the animistic to
apotheistic? Well, the main reason is
because of civilization. Okay? Because
of mass society
civilization because we chose to settle
down and learn agriculture and develop
religious
systems. All right? And with that comes
war, comes hierarchy, comes
inequality. And as such, we develop the
polyic worldview. All right? From the
polytheistic worldview, we then
transition into the monotheistic
worldview. Why? Because of Christianity.
All right. Christianity.
remember um you're usually taught that
Christianity is oh um Jesus dies and
then everyone becomes a Christian.
That's not what happened. Okay? As you
learn in this class, Christianity was a
mechanism developed by the Roman Empire
in order to
assimilate the Jews and then later on to
assimilate um barbarians who were
economic migrants into the Roman Empire.
Basically, it was a tool of control for
the Roman Empire. Okay. But then you
have this mass transition from
monotheism the Christian period into
modernism. All right. And this turning
point which is the most radical turning
point in human history is what we call
the French
Revolution. Without the French
Revolution, modernity could
not happen. All right. And um what's
amazing about the French Revolution is
it is entirely unprecedented. We've
never had we've never had anything like
this before. It was entirely
unpredictable and it was unique in human
history. All right. So we will spend the
next three classes to understand how the
French revolution happened because
without understanding the French
revolution you cannot understand future
events especially communism the rise of
communism world war II none of these
things would have been possible without
the French
revolution
okay all right so um another thing
that's really important for us to
understand is that all four worldviews
still exist today. All right, there are
still people who believe in animism,
polytheism, okay? But they're the
minority. The dominant people are still
the montheists, okay? And they're in
competition with the modernists, okay?
Who um who are who are the educated
elite, okay? Um so this cloth is still
going on today. The other thing that's
really important for us to understand
is none of these beliefs is inherently
superior to the other. Okay, you can
make the argument, you cannot make the
argument to me at least that one is
better than the other.
But new systems believe they are
superior to the other. Okay, to the
previous. So the polytheists believe
they are superior to the
animist. The monotheists think they are
superior to the polytheists and the and
the Distas think they're superior to the
montheist. Okay. And because of this
sense of superiority
um
they try to crush previous world views.
Okay. So these four worldviews are not
in competition with each other but the
new ones seek to displace the old ones
and this what's and this has led to a
lot of conflict throughout um human
history. All right. So this is the
overall framework we're working with. I
know it's a bit simple but for the
purpose of this class it's it's it's
good enough. Okay. All right. So now
what I'm going to do is explain the
framework for the next three classes.
Okay. My argument to you is the French
Revolution was ultimately a religious
crusade. That is the main
thesis of this of the next three
classes. In each class, we will
introduce different elements of this
crusade that made it possible. For a
crusade to happen, you need three
different types of geniuses. You need
the poet to envision the future. Okay,
the poet. But then you need the prophet
who has the courage to take the people
into this new land. And then you need
the prince or the conqueror. who has the
conviction and the determination to
physically conquer this new land and
expand the revolution.
Okay. So the
poet is Rouso Jean Jacqu Rouso
um he wrote the social contract. We will
be focusing on him mainly today. Okay.
He's the one who introduces the idea
that is possible to build a new world
based entirely on reason
itself. All right, that's Rouso. Then
you have the prophet. The prophet is the
one who has the courage to lead the
people into the new land even though it
may cost him his life. And this person,
his name is Maxmleon Ropes Pierre.
Okay. Maxim Rose Pier is in my
opinion one of the most
misunderstood and
underrated individuals in human history.
Um
um next class we'll focus on ropes pier.
Without ropes pier the French revolution
could not have succeeded. And then now
you need a
prince who will take the ideas of the
prophet and he will militarily expand
into the world and conquer a new world
and build a new world. And this person's
name of course is Napoleon
Bonapart.
Napoleon and this is the last class. All
right. And my argument to you today is
that without the
active cooperation of all three, if
they're not able to build on each
other's work, the French Revolution
would not have succeeded. Because if you
just look at the French Revolution, the
odds were so against the
revolutionaries, right? They were not
only against the aristocracy and their
own people, they were up against the
entire world.
Britain, Prussia, Russia, Austria,
everyone wanted wanted to destroy the
revolution before it threatened their um
their nations. So the odds were
completely against the French Revolution
but they succeeded and it was only
because of the cooperation of these
three particular types of geniuses.
Rouso the poet, Robes Pierre the prophet
and Napoleon the prince. Okay. So that's
where we will be doing these next three
classes. All right. So
um let's talk about the ideas that
underpin the French Revolution, the
Enlightenment. Okay. How do we get into
the modern period where the ideas are
now reason, debate, and progress? Okay.
So let's go back to
Dante. Dante's Divine Comedy is a
prophecy. It is a
new um understanding of the world. Okay.
So what what the divine comedy does is
what it helps people do is take all
these new structural forces that are
being unleashed onto the world and
understand it in a new way that
unleashes three major movements. Okay.
These are of course the
renaissance, the uh
reformation and the and the sic
revolution.
Okay. Now as these things are happening,
what else is happening is the gunpowder
revolution. The gunpowder
revolution. And these things combine in
order to create massive structural
changes within European society. Okay,
so we discussed this but there are three
major changes that are happening
throughout this period. The first is the
transition from
feudalism to a nation. Okay, the idea of
a nation. Okay, at first it's an
absolute monarchy but then after
revolution it transitions into a nation
state. Okay, from decentralization
interentralization basically that's the
first major change. Second major change
is from rural to urban
basically from agriculture into
industry. Okay. And the third major
change is from religion into
science. All right. And this is what
what's happening in Europe um because of
the gunpowder revolution. Now what's
important about this is with these
structural changes comes massive
demographic, political and economic
changes. Essentially what's what's
happening is that new groups of people
are being created and these groups of
people are who we call who we
collectively call the middle class.
Okay. So let's look at the middle class.
All right. So previously in Europe there
are just roughly speaking two major
groups. Okay, there's the nobility and
the clergy.
Okay, there's almost no difference
between the two because they intermar.
They come from the same families. Okay,
but they they're the leaning elite of
society. Okay, you have the tall people,
the nobility, the clergy, and then at
the other end are the peasants and
slaves.
And of but of course I mean like this is
not that simple. I mean you you always
have a middle class. You always have um
trades people. You always have people
working um in towns but they're a
minority. And what happen what's
happening now because of all all these
changes in society is they now become an
increasingly powerful
uh group of people. They're the ones who
are driving economic change. Okay. Now,
the middle class is extremely
complicated set of people. But roughly
speaking, we can divide them into three
major categories. Okay. Three major
categories. The first is what we call
the
bouroi. The bouro. Okay. Uh the bouroi
is um a French term that we use and it
comes actually from the German which is
burger. Burger means the leading
citizens of a town, the
burgers. And the leading citizens of a
town usually are the factory
owners, the merchants, the people who
trade, the bankers, the people who have
control the money, the
lawyers. Okay. So these are the bouroi.
These are the elite. Okay. And this is a
um new group of people that work very
closely with the nobility but they have
some differences. Okay. And the thing to
remember about these people is they tend
to be conservative because in terms of
status they already have um all all the
status that they want. Okay. And over
time what will happen is
that the king and nobility will
increasingly depend on the boujo for
financing. Okay? So they pay for wars,
they pay for new new industry, they pay
for roads. Okay? So the bourgeoz are the
ones who are most heavily taxed but
they're usually conservative. They're
really happy with the way things are. at
the other end
um sorry next to the boujo are what call
the petite
boujo all
right and these people are not rich but
um they're solidly in the middle class
they're comfortable where they are okay
these people are school teachers uh
maybe they're restaurant owners maybe
they're notaries okay so the thing about
these people is that they tend to be
aspirational. They're not happy with
their lives. They want more and as such
they are
opportunistic. Okay. Usually the people
who are most likely to lead the
revolution come from members of the
petite bio. Okay. So me most of the uh
leaders of the French revolution the
most radical members um were provincial
lawyers. Okay, lawyers who worked in
small cities. They're not part of the
elite, the bourja. Okay, but they're
pretty comfortable where they are. Okay,
they're the provincial elite. If you
look at the communist revolution, right,
Maong, he was a patit bourgeozi, right?
He was a provincial elite, not a Beijing
elite. All right. And the last group is
what will what will be referred to in
the future. Okay, not now as the
proletariat.
Polletariat. The proletariat are
basically
artisans, crafts people, people who work
in cities and in the urban centers and
they have a specialized craft that makes
them valuable. Okay, they're not
peasants, they're not poor, but the
problem is they are very
precarious. Okay, precarious.
What this means is that as the sonic
revolution
um pro progresses new technology will
start to replace the
artisans.
Okay. Um like a sewing
machine and as such they lose their
livelihoods. So their job their lives
are very precurious. Therefore they're
most likely they most likely tend
towards violence. So these are the foot
soldiers.
of revolutions. Okay, the petite bourz
are often the thought leaders
um but the politer are the ones who
provide the muscle. Okay. So if you look
at most revolutions this is how it
works. What's really important for us to
understand is that first of all these
categories are not strict.
Okay, there are lots of interchange
between the proletariat and the and the
peasantry. There's lot lots of
interchange between the bori and the
nobility. Okay, these categories are not
static. The other thing is
that the loyalties of each group will
change according to the
circumstance. Okay. So the petite bor is
not definite that they will rebel
against the boro. It depends on their
economic interest and it is not definite
that the peasants will work with the py
porch against the nobility. In fact
during the French revolution this is
really important. The nobility and the
peasants were working together to
suppress revolution. Why? because the
French revolution wanted to destroy the
Catholic religion and the peasants love
their religion. Okay, the peasants want
wanted to be Catholic and they want to
protect their priests. So there was a
massive civil war going on in France
between the peasants and the
proletariat. And that that would be
counterintuitive to you think it's like
why would poor people be fighting
against poor people? Well, it's because
they have different religious interests.
Okay, does that make sense? All right.
So this is a framework that I want you
guys to remember. There are different
groups. This is an
oversimplification. Um and their
loyalties will change. So during the
revolution the the loyalties will change
and it will mark different stages in the
French revolution. And you can use this
framework to also understand future
revolutions especially the communist
revolution. Okay. Um and it's also
important for us to remember that most
revolutions will fail. Okay. All
right. So
um this is this is the middle class. Now
thing thing about the middle class the
thing with with the thing about uh new
groups is
that what they have to do is they have
to establish group
solidarity. Okay. And then the way you
do that is by establishing group
identity.
So how is it that the middle class is
different from everyone
else? Okay. And as we discussed what the
middle class will
do is they will slowly adopt the
enlightenment principles of
reason,
debate and progress.
Okay, that's how they how that's how the
middle class or most members of the
aspirational middle class will try to
differentiate themselves from everyone
else by embracing the enlightenment and
that's why we have the
enlightenment. Okay. So,
uh over time these things these things
will become much more concrete. Okay.
So, what makes the middle class
identity? The first is the idea of
education. Second is the idea of
achievement. And the third is the idea
of
morality. All right? So what is the
middle class? The middle class are those
who embrace these three ideas.
Education, achievement, and morality.
Right? If you're in the middle class,
you will be much more educated than
nobility and the peasantry. You will
read books. You will read newspapers.
That's why we have newspapers. Okay?
Because middle class wants
information. Uh achievement the
achievement ethos
is I will always strive to be better. I
I want my children to be better than me.
Okay? If you're peasant, you don't
believe your children will live will
live a better life. If you're nobility,
you don't really care if your children
live a better life. But for the middle
class, it's very important that their
children live better lives. Okay? Okay,
so the idea of the achievement ethos to
work hard. Okay, so you guys should
understand this because you're all
members of the middle class in China,
right? The last is the idea of morality.
Okay, and this is really important. Um
morality is
uh especially when it comes to sexual
morality. All right, sexual morality. So
the idea is that
um if you're a poor person, the thing
about being poor is you have no control
over your body. So during this time of
industrialization, what's happening is a
lot of peasants are moving into the
cities. And what are women doing? Well,
they're becoming prostitutes. There are
tons and tons of prostitutes in these
cities at this time in Europe. Okay? You
we just walk we just walk on the street
and guess what? There are prostitutes
everywhere. So as a poor person, you
have absolutely no control over your
body. So what the middle class the way
that they differentiate themselves is by
saying that we have enough resources to
protect our bodies and if you're part of
the middle class then you're expected to
adhere to a very strict
um morality. Okay, does that make sense?
That's that's where we get the idea of
morality from from the development of
the middle class. As a middle class you
have sexual um you are much more
sexually appealer but also you have a
new idea called
childhood. If you are a poor person your
child age six starts to work. Okay at
age 10 he or she may be working in a
factory and by 12 may be dead. What the
middle class can do is give his or her
her
child a childhood. Okay, the modern
concept of childhood comes from this
period and we'll be looking at
this, right? Okay, so that's the idea
here. The Enlightenment basically was a
movement in which a new group of people,
the middle class, they've always
existed, but now they they exist in
quantity and they have more resources
than they used to have before,
especially literacy, access to
information. They have more wealth. They
have more technology. They are the
future leaders of the world. And as
such, they want to embrace a new
identity. And that's why we have the
enlightenment. Okay, the enlightenment
was basically a period when they tried
to bring the ideas of science into
society in order to create a new middle
class identity and it still exists
today. Okay. All right. So that is the
basic framework for today. Now we will
look at specific writers and thinkers of
the enlightenment. Okay. Any questions
so far? Okay, great. All right.
So let's start looking at some major
thinkers of the
enlightenment.
Okay. All right. So um today's class is
on the European Enlightenment. Now
what's really important for us to
remember is that there are major
ideological differences between the
British enlightenment and the European
enlightenment. Okay, European just means
um France, Germany, Netherlands that
that okay basically continental Europe
the ideas that develop in Europe will be
different from the ideas that develop in
Britain after French revolution we'll
look at Britain specifically but now I
just want to focus on the European
enlightenment. Okay. So please remember
that the British Enlightenment and the
European Enlightenment have contrasting
ideas even though most historians cons
consider them part of the same
historical
movement. All right. So what is
enlightenment? It is a movement to
systemize and interize Dante to create a
new European middle class identity. So
all these ideas are coming from Dante.
But there is a major difference that we
must remember. Remember the
enlightenment for the enlightenment
thinkers what God left us is the
capacity to reason. Through reason we
can access the mind of God. Okay. Reason
is the fundamental principle of the
enlightenment. That's not what Dante
said though. Okay. Dante said love is
what God gave us. Love is the light in
us. Now you think well what's really
what's the difference between love and
reason? Okay, what I will do over the
course of the semester is show you is
show you that there's actually a huge
huge difference between love and reason.
Specifically, reason is independent. You
can by yourself reason out things. But
love requires you to connect with
someone else. Either your child, your
wife, your mother, who who knows, okay?
But you must connect with someone else.
And because of because of that idea
interconnectedness, it puts a a
restraint on your reason. But if you're
capable of reasoning by yourself, you
can reason anything including
concentration camps, nuclear bombs,
uh genocide. Okay? So there's a huge
difference between love and reason. Um,
and it's really important that the
Enlightenment
thinkers see reason as a
central organizing principle of human
society and not love. Okay? So I I I
just want you guys to keep keep that in
mind as we move on. The Enlightenment um
happened mainly in salons. These are
places organized by
wealthy bour women. And these salons
were not political. They were mainly
designed to learn manners, speech,
refinement, right? Because they're
trying to differentiate themselves from
the nobility, the clergy, and the
peasantry. And one one way that that
they want to do this is through their um
education, through their knowledge,
expertise. Okay.
salons. Um, in Britain they mainly
spread ideas through coffee
houses. All right, coffee houses. So the
idea of meaning a coffee house comes
from this period in
Britain. Um, so these women uh like
Madame Labard were the ones who are
driving enlightenment um ideas. Okay.
And these salons were places for the
leading intellectuals of the time to
come and debate um
ideas. All right. So these were the
leading women of that time. All right.
So um there were there are lots and lots
of enlightenment
thinkers because this is this is a time
of literacy, right? People want to read.
There's a marketplace of ideas. So money
can be made from writing books. And
that's why you have this explosion of
ideas, the marketplace of ideas during
this time. But now I want to just go
through some of the major
thinkers of the enlightenment. Okay. The
first major thinker of the enlightenment
is Rene Deart. And Reny
Deart wanted he is a mathematician. He's
a philosopher. Um he wanted to ask two
questions. The first question is how do
we know that God
exists and how do we know the soul
exists? Okay, these are the two
questions that he is trying to grapple
with in his philosophy and he wrote a
book called meditations on first
philosophy. This is a really important
book in development of western
civilization. Okay, we will be referring
to this book um quite often for the rest
of the semester. So I want you guys to
remember this book, Meditations on First
Philosophy. And so he's asking these
questions and let's look at let's read a
few paragraphs from his book to
understand his thinking. Okay. It is
some years now since I realized how many
false opinions I had accepted as true
from childhood onwards and that whatever
I had since built on such shaky
foundations could only be hotly
doubtful. All right. So what he's doing
here is is is saying okay I want to know
if God exists but first I must ask
myself what do I believe and how do I
know if it's true or not I must look
inside myself all
right hence I saw that at some stage in
my life the whole structure would have
to be utterly demolished and that I
would have to begin again from the
bottom up if I wish to construct
something lasting and unshakable in a
sciences and And what he's saying here
is that after I examine my own beliefs,
I recognize that most my beliefs are not
true. Okay, this is a radical departure
from previous traditions where you know
something is true because someone really
smart said it. Okay, you refer to you
you you defer to authority, right?
That's a practice here we use in China
where well Confucious said this so this
must be true. And what Renear is saying
is that no that's not true. Okay. I
myself have the capacity to know if
something is true and I have a
responsibility to reflect and question
everything I know and through that
process of self-doubt, self-examination,
I can construct something that is more
truthful. Okay? And this is the idea of
enlightenment. All right? And this is
the idea of of education. You know, when
when we try to teach you critical
thinking skills, this is what we're
trying to do. Okay? trying to get you to
question things so that you may
construct a more eternal truth. All
right. But this seemed to be a massive
task and so I postponed it until I had
reached the age when one is as fit as
one will ever be to master the various
disciplines. So to get to this point,
you also have to go through a long
process of education. Okay? You just
can't be like, "Okay, I'm going to do
this right now." You have to first learn
these beliefs and then you have to go
back and then re-examine these beliefs.
I've
delayed so long that now I should be at
fault if I use up in deliberating the
time that is left for acting. The moment
has come and so today I have discharged
me my mind from all its cares and I've
carved out a space of untroubled
leisure. I'ved drawn into seclusion and
shall at last be able to devote myself
seriously without incumbrance to the
task of destroying all my former
opinions. Okay. What he's doing here is
saying that for me to discover the
truth, I just have to rely solely on my
reason, not
debate, not talking to
others, not reading old books, but by
self-examination. Okay? And so uh this
is the beginning of the book. We will
read other sections later on in in the
semester. But this this is the
introduction. Okay. So this project is a
process of quantum
self-examination. And through this
self-examination, what did he discovers
is everything is false. How do we know
the sky is blue? How do we know the sky
exists? We don't. How do I know that the
words I'm speaking make any sense? I
don't. It's a constant process of
suffocation.
Okay. But what then he recognizes what
what then he recognizes is that the only
way that I can actually engage in this
process of self-examination is through
doubt. Right? So what do I know to be
true? Doubt is true. I doubt therefore I
am. Right? You may you know the
expression I think therefore I am.
Right? It's actually I doubt therefore I
am. The Latin is kajto
arosum.
Okay. The thing that I know to be
absolutely true is my capacity to
doubt and that is who I am. Therefore, I
exist. And so the capacity to doubt is
my soul. All right. Now, how do I know
that God exists? Well, if God didn't
exist, then I would have I would not
have the capacity to doubt, right?
Someone must have given me the clue of
doubt and that must be God, whoever God
is. But now, how do I know that God is
good, right? Because God could be a
trickster, God could be the devil, and
God could be deceiving me and my
capacity to doubt will only lead me into
error. Okay, so that's that that's
question he asked now. And then and then
he says, well, because God is perfect.
If you are perfect, you're incapable of
fault.
Therefore, I know God is good. Okay? And
and obviously this makes logical sense.
This this is not logical. It's it's what
we call a tutology, right? God is
perfect. Therefore, I know God is good.
God is good. Therefore, he's perfect.
Okay? It makes no sense. But um what's
important is that Rene Deart is asking
us to challenge our assumptions about
the world to doubt to reason and he's
saying that the idea of
reason is the most powerful force in the
world more powerful than the church more
powerful than dogma more powerful than
society itself. Okay. Our individual
capacity to reason is what matters. It
is what allows us to have access to God.
Does that make sense? Right? So this is
one of the major ideas underpinning the
enlightenment. All right. Now let's move
on to Gera. Johan V Wolf Gan von Gerta.
Um he is considered the greatest German
um writer of all time and he wrote a
book called
Faust. Okay. FA and we're we'll just
read a few passages from FA but FA is
also a very quintessential enlightenment
work of art. Okay. And so um the book of
FA it's based on another book called the
book of Job which we find in the Bible.
And in the book of Job um it's about
this very pious individual who is very
faithful to God. Okay. He's very
wealthy. He has a lot of children. He's
very happy and he's very devout. He he
prays to God all the time. He makes
sacri sacrifices to God all the time. He
gives he's very he's very generous. He
has a lot of
friends. One day God is in heaven and he
has a meeting with Satan. Okay, Satan in
the Bible means adversary. So Satan is
actually an archangel, an agent, an
agent of of of God who roams the planet.
And um God is very proud of Job. And he
and he says to Satan, "Um, have you seen
Job? Do you see how faithful he is to to
me?" He's very proud. And Satan says,
"Um, God, he's only faithful to you
because he's rich." Okay? You take away
his money, you take away his children,
and he will curse you. And God says,
"Fine, I make you the spat. You can do
anything you you can do anything you
want to him, but you must not kill him."
him. Okay, that's the only condition.
So, Satan um basically makes Job's life
a living hell. All his children die in
accidents. He loses all his money. He
becomes infected with diseases. He's
old. He's and and eventually he curses
God. And he's like, why is God doing
this to me? And then God appears before
him and says, how dare you question me,
God? I create the world. What have you
done with your life? Okay. But
basically, God calls him for a long,
long time and curses Job and says, "You
as a human being have absolutely no
right to ever doubt, to ever question
me. I can do whatever I want. I'm God.
I'm a
mystery. Do not ever think you can
understand me. Do not ever believe. You
can question me." Okay? And then what
God does is he restores Job's health and
wealth. Okay? So it's a very strange
story and it's one that is that is meant
to inspire
fear among people. And so what Gerta
does that's really interesting is that
he reimagines the story of Job and turns
it into a much more confident optimistic
story that captures a spirit of the
enlightenment. Okay, does that make
sense? So the story goes like this.
False. He is a professor. He loves
learning. He's very curious. But what he
recognizes is that despite all his book
learning, he doesn't really have access
to the truth. He's not really learning
new information, new knowledge. He
doesn't feel as though he's accessing
God. So he tries
magic. Um one day the Satan and and
Satan's name here in false he is named
Mephesle. Okay, Mephes talks to God and
and Meph Mephes says to God, "You know
what? The worst thing you ever did was
allow humans the capacity to reason
because you're idiots. You're stupid. If
you're stupid and you can reason, all it
does is confuse you and make you
unhappy. And then God is like, "Well,
have you met False?" False is my
favorite person in the whole world
because he's curious. He loves learning.
Eventually, through the process of
self-exploration, he will discover the
truth. He will get there. I I have faith
in
false. And Messi says, "Fine, I'll make
you a bet. I bet you I can make him
complacent. I bet you that I can make
him not want to learn anymore to lose
his curiosity. And if I win this bet,
then false will become my servant."
Okay? His soul will be will be mine. I
will damn him to hell for eternity.
Okay? And that's a bet. All right? So,
let's look at some passages. This is
mely saying to God, their lives will be
a little easier if you not let them
glimpse the light of heaven. They call
it reason and employ it only to be more
beastial than any beast. Okay? What's
important to first remember is that here
Gerta is invoking Dante, right? Remember
Dante in the divine comedy says
that love is the light of heaven. And
here Gerta and the enlightenment
thinkers are saying that no it's reason
that is the light of heaven. In fact in
many ways false is a rewriting of the
divine comedy. Right? So Mephesus is
saying to God reason is bad because it
makes people who are stupid more
confused. And then God says do you know
false? And then says the doctor the Lord
says and my servant. Okay. My favorite
person in the whole
world. Meles. Indeed, he serves you in a
curious way. The fool is not content
with earthly food or drink. Some ferment
makes him want what is exotic, yet he's
halfconscious of his father. Okay. False
wants to understand the world. He's
curious. He's driven by his curiosity
and his
imagination. And me makes fun of him
because he'll never get there. Okay.
From heaven he claims as his the
brightest stars and from the earth all
of its highest joys, but nothing near
and nothing far away can satisfy a heart
so deeply agitated. Okay, he's just too
curious. He can't be
satisfied. And the God says, "Though he
though now he only serves me blindly
ineply, I shall soon lead him into
clarity. The gardener knows when the
sapling turns green that blossoms and
fruit will brighten future years." Okay.
So God is saying if he continues to be
curious eventually I God will lead him
into the light. Okay. So it's important
for us as humans is to be curious and
that's how we show our faith in God.
Right? Now so messes and false meet and
messes says to false listen I know you
want to know the truth about the world.
I want I know you want to experience the
whole world whole world but you can't do
it by yourself. So I will help you,
okay? I will grant you the knowledge of
the world. But if at any point you
become complacent, you stop
striving, you're happy with the way
things are, you're happy with the
moment, then you will become my servant.
Is that a deal? False. And Paul says,
"Sure." Because false does not believe
that he can ever lose his
curiosity. Okay. So what happens is all
these strange events where false uh
falls in love with a lady named Gretchen
and Gretchen falls in love with him and
um they try to have sex but the mother
gets in the way so Falls has Gretchen
kill the mother. The brother finds out
and tries to kill False. False kills the
uh brother. Gretchen get gets pregnant
and then has to kill the baby because
false has disappeared and then Gretchen
basically dies in prison. Okay, so it
sounds terrible but what happens is that
eventually Gretchen forgives False
because Gretchen goes to heaven and then
Gretch and then False has more
adventures. He becomes um a servant to
the king. He builds um um a lot of roads
and a lot of cities. He marries Helen of
Troy. He goes back in the past. Anyway,
a lot of strange things happen. Okay.
But what's happening is that he's
experiencing life for all it for all its
potential, for it all its possibilities.
And and so as he gets older, he's about
to die and me comes to collect his soul.
Okay? And this is the last speech of
false before he dies. A swamp lies there
below the hill, infecting everything
I've done. My last and greatest act of
will succeeds when that foul pool is
gone. Okay, so he is an architect and he
is an urban planner working for the
government. He's a civil servant
basically and his job is to make the
city much more livable for people. Okay,
to help to help civilize the world and
he's seeking pride in his
work succeeds when that foul pool is
gone. Okay, let me make room for many a
million. Okay, let me in. Let me make
space for more people. Not wholly
secure, but free to work on. Green
fertile fields where men and herds may
gain swift comfort from the new made
earth. Quickly settled in those hills.
Embrace pound high by a brave industrial
race. And in the center here, a paradise
whose boundaries hold back the raging
tide. And though it gnaws to enter in by
force, the common urge unites to hold
its course. Okay. So, he's taking pride
in all that he's accomplished and that
he will accomplish. Okay. He's taking
pride in this moment when he's actively
contributing to the betterment of
civilization. But because he's taking
pride in this moment, he's now lost a
bet to me, right? He's now become
complacent. He wants to live in the
moment. You can't do
that. Yes. I've surrendered to this
thought insistence. The last word wisdom
ever has to say. He only earns his
freedom in existence who's forced to win
them freshly every day. Childhood,
manhood, age, vigorous years surrounded
by dangers they'll spend here. I wish to
gaze again on such a land free earth
where a free race and freedom stand.
Okay. So to be alive means to constantly
struggle to progress things. Okay. And
this is it. Then to the moment I dare
say stay a while you are so lovely. He
wants to stay in this moment
forever through eons then never to fade
away this path of mind through all
that's earthly anticipating here its
deep enjoyment now I savor it that that
highest moment okay in this moment when
he feel he's contributed to development
of society he feels at peace he feels
fulfilled
Okay. And so the irony is that at this
moment when he's most fulfilled, he
should not he should now be damned to
hell, right?
But what happens as Mephestles is about
to claim false soul is angels appear and
steal it from from messes. Okay. The
angels pure incandescent whom its flames
bless blissful with goodness is their
existence. Gather together rise now and
praise spirit can breathe here in pure
waves. So God has come to save false
They rise carrying away the immortal
part of false. False false soul is now
in heaven. Nephes says, "How then? Where
did they vanish to? You took me by
surprise, you adolescence. Now with what
they've salvaged from the tomb as their
own prize, they've flown off to heaven.
They've stolen a great and unique
treasure that noble soul mortgaged to my
pleasure. They've snatched it away with
cunning even. But whom can I even
complain to anyway?" Okay. So, Mephes
knows he's been tricked, but he has no
say in the matter. Okay. And so, false,
it is considered the greatest work of
German literature. And the main message
is God loves us. God wants us to be
curious. God wants us to explore, to
challenge ourselves, to grow. And if we
do that, God will always protect us no
matter how many stupid things we do.
Okay? God is ultimately about
forgiveness and love and mercy and
kindness and
generosity. So that's a very optimistic
and confident view of the world,
right? Uh any questions so
far? Okay, let's move on to Emanuel
Kant. Emanuel Kant is the greatest
philosopher who ever lived. We'll be
spending a lot of time on Emanuel Kant
throughout the semester. Okay. So I
introduce you to him here and he wrote a
very influential essay called what is
enlightenment? Why do we have
enlightenment? Okay. All right. So
enlightenment is man's emergence from a
self-imposed knowledge. Knowledge is the
inability to use one's own reasoning
without another's guidance. This
knowledge is self-imposed if its cause
lies not in lack of understanding but in
indecision and lack of courage to use
one's own mind. one another's guidance.
Dear to know have the courage to use
your own understanding is therefore the
model of the enlightenment. Okay. So
what he's saying here is that you're
students and I'm the teacher. Okay. I'm
enlightened because I'm using my reason.
But you're not enlightened because
you're not you because you're relying on
my
reason. Right? And what he's saying is
that it's not because you lack the
capacity to reason that's a problem.
It's because you guys are lazy, right?
It's just easier for you to just sit sit
there and take notes rather than to
actually read these texts for yourself
and understand them yourself. That's why
we rely on me. Okay. But well, but if
you don't ever rely on yourself, you can
never be free to think it. Does that
make sense? That's what he's saying
here. Laziness and cowardice are the
reasons why such a large part of mankind
gladly remain minders all their lives
long after nature has freed them from
external eternal external guidance.
Okay, you have the capacity to reason.
You can just read these things by
yourself, but you're lazy and you're
cowardly. Okay, you don't want you don't
want to make a mistake. Okay, you don't
be wrong.
Thus, it is very difficult for the
individual to work himself out of
knowledge which has become almost second
nature to him. He has even grown to like
it and is at first really incapable of
using his own understanding because he
has never been permitted to try it.
Okay. So, everyone can do it but only a
few can do it. So, what's the solution
to this problem? The solution is free
and open debate. Does that make sense?
If you're able to access information, if
you're able to access different points
of view, then you're able to to hear the
truth for yourself. Okay? Does that make
sense? All right. So, you don't want to
find the truth for yourself. But if
you're able to hear the truth, hear the
opinions of others, then you can make up
for your mind, make up your own mind as
what the truth is. And you can because
you have access to reason that God
implanted in you. Okay, that's the logic
here. It is more nearly possible,
however, for the public to enlighten
itself. Indeed, if it is only given
freedom, enlightenment is almost
inevitable. There will always be a few
independent thinkers even among the
self-appointed guardians of the
multitude. Okay, so this idea of of
reason, debate, and
progress. If there's a debate, if
everyone is able to hear different
opinions, then society will almost
always progress. Okay? Does that make
sense? This enlightenment requires
nothing but freedom. And the most
innocent of all that may be called
freedom. Freedom to make public use of
one's reason in all matters. Now, I hear
the cry from all sides. Do not argue.
The officer says,"Do not argue. Drill
the tax collector." Do not argue. Pay
the pastor. Do not argue. Believe. Only
one ruler in the world would says,
"Argue as much as you please, but obey."
We find restrictions on freedom
everywhere. But which restrictions is
harmful to enlightenment? Which
restriction is innocent and which
advances enlightenment? I reply, "The
public use of one's reason must be free
at all times and this alone can bring
enlightenment to mankind." He is arguing
for
absolute freedom of
expression. Okay? Even if it's hate
speech, even even if you say racist
things, you're still allowed to say it
because people have reason and therefore
the capacity to judge for himself or
herself what is true. Whenever you
censor something, you're denying freedom
to
people. Okay? So this is an absolutist
understanding of freedom and this
becomes the foundation for of course um
the American constitution or the
American
revolution. In view of this he as
preacher is not free and ought not to be
free since he is carrying out the orders
of others. On the other hand as a
scholar who speaks to his own public
through his writings the minister in the
public use of his reason enjoys
unlimited freedom to use his own reason
and to speak for himself. Okay, this is
a really important idea. All right, so
I'm your teacher. Okay, I'm I'm your
teacher. Now, I can perceive myself in
different ways. I can perceive myself as
a employee of a school in
China. Therefore, I must be aware of
uh censorship laws in China. I must be
aware of what I can teach you and what
and what I cannot teach you. I must also
be aware that my main responsibility is
to make you a citizen of China and
therefore make you feel good about
China. Okay? If I see myself as an
employee of a school in China, but if I
see myself as
a free
individual in a service of human
progress, then my job is to enlighten
you as to the possibilities of human
reason. Right? So I must be honest with
you. I must challenge you to think for
yourself. I must give you the capacity
to for you to think for yourself. Okay?
Therefore I will not tell you what Khan
says. I will show you what Khan says so
that you can you can by yourself
interpret what he's saying. Does that
make sense? Okay. That's the difference.
You can either see yourself as an
employee who is just making money in the
service of others or as a citizen of the
world. as a citizen dedicated to the
progress of human civilization. Okay,
that's your
choice. But a society of ministers say
church council have the right to commit
itself by oath to a certain unimal
doctrine in order to secure perpetual
governorship over all its members and
through them over the people. I say that
this is quite impossible. Such a
contract concluded to keep all further
enlightenment from humanity is simply
null and void, even if it should be
confirmed by the sovereign power by
parliaments and the most solemn
treaties. An epoch cannot include a pack
that will commit succeeding ages,
prevent them from increasing their
significant insights, purging themselves
of errors, and generally progressing in
enlightenment. That would be a crime
against human nature whose proper
destiny lies precisely in such progress.
Okay, this is a radical statement. What
he's saying is that I'm I'm of an older
generation than you, right? I have
absolutely no right to tell you what to
think. I have absolutely no right to
tell you what to think. I can show you
possibilities. I can argue with you, but
I must not enforce my ideas on you
because that would limit human progress.
Progress is determined by a new
generation's capacity to question and
negate a previous generation's ideas.
Okay, does that make sense?
Right. All right. So, um this is
Voltater. Um Voltier I I don't really
want to spend too much time on, but
Voltater is considered a celebrity of
the Enlightenment. Okay? He was very
famous at that time because he is what
we what we call today a troll. Okay, a
troll. Why? Because he's always making
fun of the nobility and the clergy, the
powers that be. And as such, the middle
class basically um worshiped him. Okay,
they love his contributions. But he
himself was not a very deep thinker.
Okay, he himself was not a great
thinker. So I don't want to spend too
much time on him. All right. Um so let's
go move on to Jon Rouso who is the most
influential enlightenment thinker in
France. It is it is his ideas that will
drive the French revolution. Okay. All
right. So he wrote a very influential
book called a meal. Emil is his treatis
on education. How should you best
educate children? Okay. All right. So
let's just read some basic passages.
If the infant sprang at one bound from
its mother's breast to the age of
reason, the present type of education
would be quite so suitable. But his
natural growth calls for quite a
different training. The mind should be
left undisturbed till its faculties have
developed. For while it is blind, it
cannot see the torch you offer it, nor
can it follow through the vast expanse
of ideas of path so faintly traced by
reason that the best eyes can scarcely
follow it. Okay. So, what he's saying
here, and it's a very controversial
idea. What he's saying here is
that kindergarten and primary school
make no
sense. Kids come into school to learn
math, to learn language, right? But the
problem is that their faculty for reason
has not fully developed. Okay? It's like
me asking you to uh fly even though you
don't have wings. So, what he's saying
is this. before the age of 12, let kids
play. Because if you ask them to come to
school, all that will do is screw up
their
minds, right? If a child is crawling and
you make the child walk, all that's
going to do is make the
bones deformed, okay? It's going to
really screw up the legs. And that's
what what we're saying. Do not ever send
kids to learn anything before the age of
12 because their faculty of reason has
not developed before the age of 12. And
guess what guys? This is the idea of
childhood. Okay, childhood. Children
should should be allowed to play
um until the age of 12 and it comes from
rousole.
Okay, does that make sense?
Therefore, the education of the earliest
years should be merely negative.
Negative just means like don't have kids
jump in the pool by themselves. Okay?
But don't be positive. Don't make them
learn
mathematics. It consists not in teaching
virtue or truth, but in preserving the
heart from vice and from the spirit of
error. If only you could let well alone
and get others to follow your example.
If you could bring your scholar to the
age of 12, strong and healthy, but
unable to tell his right hand from his
left, the eyes of his understanding
would be open to reason as soon as you
began to teach him. Free from prejudices
and free from habits. There would be
nothing in him to counteract the effects
of your labors in your hands. He would
soon become the wisest of man. By doing
nothing to begin with, you would end
with a prodigy of education. Okay,
that's the secret of education. Before
age 12, leave the kid alone. Make sure
he's he or she is healthy. Make sure he
or she is eating well. But do not teach
mathematics. Okay? Because because by
leaving the child alone, you free the
child from bad mental habits. You allow
the child to think for himself or
herself. Okay? So the very idea of
childhood comes from
Rouso. And this is this is an idea that
a lot of uh middle class parents will
adopt. Okay, I myself
um also believe very heavily in this
idea. I I'm not tr I don't want to send
my kids to school before age 12,
possibly even age 16. Okay, I don't tr I
work in a school so I don't really trust
schools. I don't trust teachers. It's it
it's like being a cook and you work in a
restaurant. Like you would you would
never actually go eat in a restaurant
because you know how how they make the
food. Okay. All
right, let's
continue. There are two classes of men
who are constantly engaged in body
activity. Peasants and savages. Okay,
there are these peasants who work the
farm and these savages who run around in
the force all day. Okay, so you think
there's no difference, but in fact
there's a world of
difference. And certainly neither of
these of these pays least attention to
the cultivation of the mind. Peasants
are rough, coarse, and clumsy. Savages
are noted not only for their keen
senses, but for great subtlety of mind.
Savages are really smart. Peasants are
really dull.
Why? Generally speaking, there is
nothing duller than a peasant or sharper
than a savage. What is the cause of this
difference? The peasant has always done
as he was told, what his father did
before him, what he himself has always
done. He's the creature of habit. He
spends his life almost like an automat
an an automaton on the same task. Hab
and obedience have taken a place of
reason. The case of the savage is very
different. He is tied to no one place.
He has no prescribed task, no superior
to obey. He knows no law but his own
will. He is therefore forced to reason
at every step he takes. He can neither
move nor walk without considering the
consequences. Thus, the more his body is
is exercised, the more alert is his
mind. His strength and his reason
increase together and each helps to
explore the other. The savage is an
explorer. The savage is a problem
solver. The savage is free and
independent to make his own destiny.
That's the difference.
Okay? So if you want to educate your
child well, then let the child be a
savage and not a
peasant. Oh man, seek no further for the
author evil thou art he. There's no evil
but the evil you do or the evil you
suffer and both come from yourself. Evil
in general can only spring from this
order and in the order of the world I
find a never failing system. Evil in
particular cases exists only in the mind
of those who experience it. And this
feeling is not the gift of nature but
the work of man himself. Pain has little
power over those who have thought little
look neither before nor after. Take away
our fatal progress. Take away our faults
and our vices. Take away man's handiwork
and all is
well. If you take children out of
school, you let them play by themselves
whatever they want. Guess what? They
become smart. They become resilient.
They become educated. They become
curious. They love
learning. So we if we try to build
structure, if we try to build
civilization, if we move children away
from the state of nature, we can only
screw things
up. Schools are not designed to educate
children. Schools are first and foremost
designed to control
children. Right? Why? because we don't
like kids running around. Okay, it's
that simple. They're not meant for kids.
They're meant for adults so that parents
don't don't actually have to see them
and teachers don't have to deal with
them. Okay, so that's what Rouso is
saying and he's he's absolutely
right. All right. Um so that was Emil.
Now Rouso also wrote a really famous
book called this course on the origin of
inequality which will have a major
impact on the French revolution and
enlightenment. Okay. And it's the idea
of private property. Where does priv
private property come
from? The first man who having enclosed
a piece of ground be thought himself of
saying this is mine and found people
simple enough to believe him was the
real founder of civil society. Okay. So
we have society because some people want
property, private
property. Okay.
From how many crimes, wars, and murders?
From how many horrors and misfortunes
might not anyone have saved mankind by
pulling up the stakes or filling up the
ditch and crying to his fellows. Beware
of listening to this impostor. You're
undone if you if you want to forget that
the fruits of the earth belong to us all
and the earth itself to nobody. What
he's saying is
this. Suddenly one day some people in
our society are like, "Oh, this is mine.
This ground is mine. you can't come
here. We should have all been like,
"What are you talking about? That makes
no
sense. How can you claim this ground for
yourself?" Well, we didn't do that. In
fact, we claim our own ground or we let
we we let let them have their own crown
ground. And because of this, because of
the idea, because of the idea of private
property, we now have
inequality,
patriarchy, war.
Okay. This is where war and patriarchy
and inequality come from because of some
people's insistent on having private
property. All right. Okay. Any questions
so far? Okay. Is this all clear to you?
All right. So, let's move on to the
final book. The social contract. Okay.
The social contract is the bible of the
French revolution. It is the um book
that is most influent in the most
influential in development of the
thinkers of the French revolution. All
right. The most famous sentence um the
the sentence that begins a social
contract
is man is born free and everywhere he is
in change. Here is one who thinks he is
the master of others yet is more
enslaved than they are. Okay. So we were
born free but we choose to become
slaves. But not only that, the people
who have enslaved us think they're our
masters, but in fact they're more
enslaved than us because they are
trapped by the system. You understand?
Slavery is a system that enslaves
all. Slavery is not a system where a few
oppressed the others. Slavery is a
system where an idea has oppressed
everyone, especially the
masters. Right?
We see at once that on this account of
things certain questions can be laid
aside. Whose business it is to make
laws? There are acts of the general
will. Is the prince above the law? No,
because he is a member of the state. Can
the law be unjust? No, because nothing
is unjust towards itself. How can we be
both free and subject to laws? There's
no problem about this because the laws
are nothing but records of our
violations. Okay. So, this is a really
important idea um that I need to explain
to you. All right? Right? And it becomes
a basis for a new type of society uh
promoted by the French revolution. All
right. So um Rouso is trying to reason
from general principles as to how to
form a good society. Okay. A social
contract where everyone chooses to
participate in a society and is not
compelled to participate in a society.
And what he says is this. There are two
types of will. There's a general will
and there's the particular will. Okay,
general will is what we can agree on if
we are left to reason by
ourselves. Particular will is what we
believe if we are part of a group of
people. Okay, a part of a interest. So
let's let's just say for
example B the central government in
China is like I want to spend $10
billion on roads on new
roads where should we invest this money
okay general will is everyone agrees
that we should invest these roads where
they're most needed in China right maybe
Joe maybe you the poorest parts because
it will do the most good we can all
agree on that right but because we are
in Beijing
we would be like no you should put the
money in Beijing that's a particular
will okay so in other words society if
it is to function well must be based
entirely on the general will and negate
the particular will on the common
interest and that's why everything works
because if laws are based on the general
will then all the laws are acceptable to
people because they the laws are just an
expression of the general will and the
king, he's just acting out the general
will. So the king is acceptable to
everyone. Okay, does that make sense?
The problem with this, of course, is
that that's not how the world works.
Okay? There's actually no one in the
world who's like, "Oh, I should do this
because of the general will." It's
always a particular will. Right? Does
that make sense? And so this is the
major
um divergence between the French
Revolution and American Revolutions. The
French Revolution, it is fundamentally
idealistic. It believes that people are
capable
of considering the common interest. The
American Revolution denies this. Okay?
So, we will discuss the American
Revolution later on, but I I just want
you to be aware of this. Okay? The
French Revolution is based on the idea
of the general will that everyone is
capable of reason of promoting the the
common interest. The American Revolution
refuses to believe this.
Okay? All right. Each of us puts his
person and all his power in common under
the supreme direction of the general
will. And in our corporate capacity, we
receive each member as an indivisible
part of the whole. Okay? So as long as
we are capable of reason, which we are,
we can understand the general
will. That the populace held its
celebrations on a basis of adequate
information while the citizens
communicating with one another. what
emerged from all that particular wills
should would always be the general will
and the decision would always be good.
Okay. So if you only think about the
common interest everyone would come to
the same conclusion about everything.
Okay. If the general will is to emerge
clearly, it's important that there
should be no partial society within the
state and that each citizen should think
only his own thoughts, which was
indeed, I'm continually astonished that
such a simple sign of good government
isn't recognized or perhaps many do
recognize it but aren't honest honest
enough to say so. What's the purpose of
any particular association? the
preservation and prosperity of its
members. And what is the shest sign of
their preservation and prosperity? Their
number and the population growth. That's
the sign you're looking for. Other
things being equal, the unquestionably
best government is the one under which
the population increases most without
external help from naturalizing
foreigners or establishing colonies. The
government under which the population
shrinks is the worst. Over to you
calculators. Count, measure, compare.
Okay, this is a really important idea
here. What Russo is saying is that not
only can we deduce good government from
general principles, but good government
can be measured.
Okay. So we can know how we are doing as
society through measurement by measuring
things by no by counting things.
Okay. Count, measure, compare. And
that's what progress means. Now what
we'll know what we will learn later on
is this is actually a really dumb idea.
Okay. But for now I want you to be aware
of this and the French revolution will
embrace
this and that's why um in the French
revolution they will introduce the
metric system. The metric system comes
from the French revolution and the
French and the metric system is now used
by every country in the world except
two. Right? There are the two countries
in the world who don't use the metric
system. They
are you guys know there there exactly
two countries in the world that do not
use a metric system. They are can you
guess these two these two countries are
the countries that are most that were
most against the French revolution.
These countries
are America and Britain.
Okay. Yeah. It's true. In China we use
Celsius, right? When you go to America,
they don't use Celsius. They use
Fahrenheit. Okay? And when you go to
Britain, they use something called
imperial system. So, so, so, so, so just
be aware when, when you go to America,
you will hear terms like, oh, uh, 12
yards, and you're like, what is 12
yards? Okay. So, so, so they don't
actually use the metric system in
America, but but everywhere else does.
But I'm wrong to speak of a Christian
republic. Those two terms are mutually
exclusive. Christianity preaches only
servitude and independence. Its spirit
is so favorable to tyranny that it
always profits by such a regime. Genuine
Christians are made to be slaves and
they know it and don't mind much. This
short life counts for too little in
their eyes. Okay. So is rejecting
religion in government. This idea of
separation of church and state which
becomes the basis for the French nation
state. It's a very important idea and
during the French revolution this will
lead to civil wars between the peasants
who want to be Christians and the
revolutionaries who want to establish a
secular
state. The domas of civil religion ought
to be few, simple and exactly worded
with no explanation or commentary. Its
positive dharmas are the existence of a
mighty intelligent and beneficient
divinity, possessed of foresight and
providence, the life to come, the
happiness of the just, the punishment of
the wicked, the sanity of the social
contract and the laws and just one dogma
of exclusion in the exclusion of
intolerance which is a feature of the
cult we have rejected. Okay. So what
Russ is saying here is that the new
society should now have a new religion a
state religion that is based on
reason. Okay. And this new religion of
reason must reject all other religions
because these religions are intolerant
of each other. And that's why in France
today there's so much conflict between
uh there's so much conflict in in
society. Okay? you you have a lot of
Islamic immigrants and they're always in
conflict with the French state because
the French state in insist on secular um
on a secular religion but they Islamists
want to practice their own religion.
Okay. Okay. So that's it. Okay. So these
ideas that we looked at will now become
the basis of the French Revolution.
Right. So next class we'll look at the
French
Revolution. All right. So, so I I know
this was a lot, but are there any
questions about what we've learned so
far? Why are so loyal to the religion?
Excuse me. Why would so loyal to the
religion? Why are peasants so loyal to
the religion? Right. Yes. Okay. Great.
Great question. All right. Sorry. Let me
um All
right. So, what you learn in this class
is that the Christian religion
It is something that is um adopted okay
or enforced but over generations right
over the centuries it becomes part of
your tradition right so what is
religion
okay people okay what do we know that
people are loyal to people are loyal to
their home right their
land that's true right people like being
in a place they they don't want to move.
Most people in the world don't want to
move. If you give people the choice of
like of Chinese the choice of like just
moving to America, you think everyone
would go, but no, no, no. Most people
would not go because they want to live
where they grew up. Okay? So, they're
loyal to the land, but they're loyal to
the
family, they're loyal to um
tradition or
culture, they're loyal to food.
Okay. Right. This is true for most
people. If you grew up eating, I don't
know,
rice, you don't want to eat potatoes.
You want to eat rice. Okay. So, what
this tells us is
that people are first and
foremost people of habit. Okay? Does
that make sense? Why why are people of
habit? Because this is a really
important idea. Okay? Um, and I know
this is a strange idea because it feels
good. Do you understand? Because when
you do something out of habit, you feel
good about yourself. When you break this
habit, you feel bad about yourself. And
the way that the only way that you know
if something is good or bad is how you
feel about it. Okay?
Right? Like you're eating rice and
you're happy eating rice because you've
been doing this all your life. But then
and now you're you're eating potatoes
and like it kind of tastes weird. But I
tell you, hey, no, no, eating potatoes
is better for you. It's how it's more
more nutritious. It's cheaper. You don't
care. Okay? It's all about feeling good.
So, you resort to habit. And habit is in
the land, the family, the tradition, and
the food. Does that make sense? And
guess
what? These ideas are all encapsulated
in religion. Because religion is what
determines your culture, your food, it's
what your family practices. It is your
connection to your family. It's
connection to your land. Okay? And
that's why people will die for the
religion because religion is really a
metaphor or an encapsulation of all
these things that people understand and
know and
love. Does that make sense? Okay. Now
what you will learn in this class is
people don't just don't die for religion
they also die for ideas which
include the
nation right the nation state because
all that because because what you will
learn in this class is what the French
revolution will do is sort a process
where
religion becomes part of the
nation. our ideas of religion become
transplanted into the
nation. Okay? So people will also die
for the nation. That's why you have
these incredibly devastating wars like
World War I and World War II where
people will die for the nation. Okay?
And they won't even think about it. But
it starts in the it starts during the
French Revolution. Okay? Does that make
sense to you? Okay. Great.
So how do
you Okay. All right. Good question. So
how can a religion be based on reason?
All right.
So traditionally
religion is given us to by God. Okay?
Right? Every religion is like well we
have this religion because God told us
to believe in him. Okay? So so and the
way you do that is through
priests who then tell you what to
believe. Okay. So this is the way that
most religion is practiced. Right?
What the enlightenment thinkers are
saying especially Rouso is no no no no
no this system doesn't really work right
because you have
reason and therefore you have the
capacity to access God so you don't
really need priest right so we can just
think
reasonably what religion should be like
and from principles you can deduce
the
religion, right? Okay, does that make
sense? Now, if you just reason from
first principles about religion should
be like, what are they? Well, first of
all, there is a God. Okay, first of all,
there is a God. Second of all is that
there is heaven and hell. You do good
things, you go to heaven. If you do bad
things, you go to hell. Right? That's
second thing. Third thing
is good people go to heaven. Therefore,
you should do good. Okay? And then
fourth would be
like if you believe in these things, you
are free to believe anything else. For
example, you're like, I don't know, I I
believe that animals have the same
rights as humans. Well, that doesn't
contradict what we already believe.
Therefore, you can believe that animals
can go to heaven as well. Okay, do you
understand? So what Russo is saying is
that for just from general principles
just because just if you're able to
exercise reason by yourself you you
should be able to deduce the basic
principles of an organized state
religion and that's what he does in in
the social contract and it becomes a
basis again for the French revolution.
Okay does that make
sense? All
right any more questions? Okay. Um
great. Okay. So I apologize for um the
length of this class but but the French
solution is really complicated and I
really need to explain some basic ideas
to you. Okay. So next class we'll do
roast pier, right?